what's up everybody
jermaine here and today i'm going to
show you how to make a
super easy and extra sweet date night
dinner for two
all in one pan to start we're going to
add our mayonnaise
next egg yolk lemon juice
dijon mustard hot sauce parsley
old bay salt lemon zest
and now we're going to whisk this all
together
now that that's all whisked together
let's go ahead and add the crab meat now
don't be cheap
y'all get this jumbo lump no claw meat
no imitation
gotta do it up all right now gently i
repeat
gently mix this together you want to
keep
all those lumps whole or as close to
hole as possible
and you want to feel like you want a
fancy day so don't break up the lumps of
crab all right
lastly you want to add your ritz
crackers because they're buttery and
delicious
now that that's all mixed up we're going
to throw some plastic wrap on top
and toss it in the fridge for about 30
minutes to an hour just to let those
crab cakes form and that way they don't
fall apart
this is a really simple way to bring
some elegance into your meal
first we're going to toss these in a
little bit of olive oil and then set
them aside
next we're going to throw down some
flour and roll out our puff pastry
and then we're going to cut it into four
equal squares
and brush the center of each square with
dijon mustard
place a slice of prosciutto in each
square then top with four asparagus
spirits and
two slices of bread rotate each square
so the corners up
creating a diamond shape and repeat with
the remaining pieces
add your bundles to the top half of the
prepared baking sheet
brush with egg wash and sprinkle with
everything
bagel seasoning and then put it in the
fridge while you assemble the rest of
your dinner
now we're going to form these crab cakes
now gently grab
a nice handful of crabmeat and
form it into a mound this is going to
make two pretty large crab cakes
next we're going to brush this with
melted butter put it back in the fridge
and assemble that dessert
what's a romantic dinner without dessert
so that's why i'm making these skillet
brookies
first we're going to microwave the
butter and chocolate chips until
everything is melted
we're going to let that sit for 2
minutes before whisking it together now
we're going to combine
granulated sugar brown sugar vanilla and
then salt
[Music]
next whisk in the egg yolk
[Music]
sift the flour and cocoa powder together
in the bowl
and then use a spatula to fold it in
pour your brownie batter into a greased
six inch oven safe skillet
arrange seven cookies on top of the
brownie batter
lastly scatter large chunks of cookie
dough
on top this is going to go on the bottom
left-hand corner of our baking sheet
this is looking good the wife's going to
love this
now it's time to put it in the oven for
30 to 35 minutes
but cover the brookie with aluminum foil
after 15 minutes
coarsely chop the remaining cookies and
set them aside for later
while we wait we're going to make our
aioli
this aioli is really easy to make all
you have to do is combine
mayonnaise dijon mustard
hot sauce turmeric
lemon pepper seasoning old bay seasoning
fresh dill garlic
and fresh lemon juice
[Music]
all right that's it for the aioli the
only thing left to do is to pull our pan
out the oven and put our finishing
touches on it
yo you see this this looks crazy
man she's really gonna be impressed with
this especially this brookie like i
can't even
bake this thing right here looks like a
professional did it
no no me there's only one thing left to
do that's to give my wife and see what
she thinks
wow this looks so good i'm so proud of
you babe
thank you whoa where do you try this
crab cake though
[Music]
mmm oh my gosh
love that i can taste the dill it's so
hearty and i love that you use
so much lump crab meat in there it's
amazing
wow i want to try this brookie though oh
my gosh
it smells amazing i need some
is it good it was too good i think i got
cavity let me get in here
get in there girl um
wow it's so rich and flavorful i love it
it's like everything i want in one so
what do you think babe how about i do on
this date night
you did amazing this is beautiful thanks
you did such a great job look at that
everything i want
on one pan let's go there you have it
one sheet date night dinner we're gonna
go finish the rest of our evening i'm
jermaine rawlings
see you next time oh yes
[Music]